[Música]
[Aplausos]
líderes
pensemos por unos segundos en aquellas
personas personajes grupos o equipos
que por su manera influenciar o los
logros que han obtenido en sus vidas o
en las de los demás
consideramos líderes
esos que se nos vienen a la mente por su
manera de influenciar
innovar y haber cambiado el mundo
les muestro algunos ejemplos de
respuesta que tuve esta pregunta me han
nombrado médicos bomberos
superhéroes próceres multimillonarios
presidentes y muchos más
pero saben lo que ninguno me nombró
a los docentes
comencé me y el transcurso de un
apasionante mundo que es el del
liderazgo a partir de cursos que he
realizado estos años con excelentes
docentes y lo que más me interesó de
este tema es que el liderazgo no sólo se
ha aplicado en empresas u organizaciones
que lo escuchan que lo habitual escuchar
por ejemplo la frase que mejor lo
representa es ser jefe no implica ser
líder sino en cualquier ámbito incluso
en nuestras propias vidas
soy docente del año 2011 llevo 10 años
transcurridos en esta hermosa carrera
pero nunca dejé de estudiar hoy en día
estoy finalizando mi segundo curso de
posgrado por lo tanto tengo ambas
visiones del ámbito educativo la del
alumno y la del docente
por lo tanto les quiero mostrar en esta
presentación la importancia y lo
fundamental del liderazgo del docente en
la nueva educación
porque si cierto el jefe no implica ser
líder ser docente
tampoco
veamos esta imagen es un aula que puede
tener de 60 a 70 años o más esta foto
muestra la educación tradicional
centrada en el docente donde este era
mejor cuanto más sabía de la materia
las clases serán principalmente
unidireccionales
este sistema fue diseñado en otra época
para otras generaciones y con un
contexto económico social de aquel
momento hagamos un poco de memoria de la
última vez que estuvimos sentados en un
aula
no cambio mucho este formato no
ahora si sabes lo que si cambiaron son
los estudiantes que están sentados en
esos bancos
en un momento el profesor decía copien
todo que voy a borrar
pánico
los alumnos de antes copiaban todo de lo
más rápido que podían tratando de juntar
la mayor cantidad de información posible
en los apuntes hoy en día eso también
cambio los docentes les transmitimos que
compartimos del material digital
presentaciones apuntes y si copiamos
algo en el pizarrón ellos utilizan
nuevas tecnologías para ahorrar tiempo y
que le dan más satisfacción
los cambios generacionales impactan
fuertemente en la sociedad y la
educación
no es la excepción
antiguamente el alumno asistía a clases
con el objetivo y la motivación de
conseguir un título
para que en el futuro pueda conseguir un
mejor trabajo y por ende una mejor
calidad de vida
ahora este paradigma ha cambiado también
hoy en día
esa mejor calidad de vida que busca el
estudiante es otra no es la misma había
antes
por lo tanto
y esto hay que tenerlo en cuenta para
comprender el porqué de esta charla
ahora los invito a que nos sumerjamos no
hay mejor manera de decirlo en esta
situación no estamos en un barco en el
medio de la tormenta
que sienten
yo
siento soledad
angustia temor miedo
no sé por qué estoy ahí la verdad
tampoco veo un destino donde quiero
llegar no sé si el barco está a la
deriva o tiene un capitán en fin mucha
incertidumbre no
formó parte del equipo de tutorías desde
el año 2012 en esta universidad
donde acompañamos a los alumnos del
primer año durante su inicio en la
transición
universitaria y su vida universitaria y
créanme que muchos de ellos se sienten
cómo nos sentimos nosotros recién en
este barco
por eso necesitamos comprender sus
ideales sus ilusiones sus limitaciones
y sus posibilidades
para poder ponernos al servicio de ellos
y que sean exitosos
ahora reflexionemos pensemos unos
segundos más en los mejores docentes que
tuvimos qué características tenían que
dejaron ella esa huella en nosotros esos
que son un ejemplo
y que nos vienen a la mente por habernos
dado mucho más que el contenido de un
programa
algunas respuestas que
que obtuve a esta consigna fueron estas
palabras de benach a con personas
confiables motivadoras innovadoras
etcétera fíjense que estas palabras
hablan por sí solas y muestran fuertes
características de liderazgo por lo
tanto los invito de los docentes tomemos
esta característica del liderazgo para
que los estudiantes se sientan motivados
y trabajen duro en lograr sus objetivos
tenemos que poner especial atención en
hacer el esfuerzo en llegarles hacerles
llegar este mensaje
que esos bancos que ven ahí son es el
mejor lugar para que ellos hagan su
inversión el aula y un establecimiento
educativo
para esto vamos a tener que trabajar muy
fuerte en la motivación pensemos que por
estar sentados en el mismo lugar en la
misma aula los alumnos
no son iguales
en general lo que vemos lo que ellos nos
muestran es esta punta del aire pero
todo lo demás
lo que no vemos
es lo que el estudiante realmente es
siente piensa y padece
entonces les propongo que tratemos de
conocerlo más
utilicemos el concepto de educación
centrada en el estudiante y así tratar
de identificar sus necesidades genuinas
ahora les quiero mostrar algo muy
interesante sobre todo por la analogía
que se puede hacer no esto está tomado
el libro de james hunter la paradoja
donde plantea un antiguo paradigma del
liderazgo servicial apuntado a
organizaciones y yo lo tomo como una
analogía al ámbito educativo veamos
plantea de un sistema verticalista en
una organización los rangos inferiores
suelen estar al servicio de las
necesidades de los rangos superiores por
ejemplo el empleado al servicio de las
necesidades del jefe el jefe al servicio
de las necesidades del gerente y así
sucesivamente y todos ellos
de espaldas al cliente
si hacemos una analogía como dije al
ámbito educativo
muchas veces pasa algo parecido
los ayudantes los jefes de cátedra están
al servicio de las necesidades del
docente el docente al servicio de las
autoridades y todos ellos a su vez la
espalda de los estudiantes
qué pasa en el primer caso del cliente
lleva a la competencia pero en el caso
de los estudiantes pueden dejar la
materia dejar la carrera
en resumen desmotivarse y dejar de
estudiar que es lo que no queremos
entonces plantea un nuevo paradigma del
liderazgo
donde dice que
ese sistema verticalista está bien que
sea así pero debe ser con la pirámide
invertida donde en una organización los
rangos superiores estén al servicio de
los rangos inferiores y todos ellos a su
vez al servicio del cliente y así lograr
la mayor satisfacción
haciendo la misma analogía
las autoridades tienen que estar de
servicio al cuerpo docente y todos ellos
en conjunto al servicio de los
estudiantes
de esta forma el estudiante se va a
sentir acompañado y va a ser consciente
de que tiene a quien recurrir en caso de
necesitar algo
y entonces bernardo bárcena en su libro
el liderazgo de francisco plantea tres
acciones que podemos tomar para ejercer
efectivamente el liderazgo servicial en
una organización lo vuelvo a tomar como
analogía al ámbito educativo bernardo
dice que los estudiantes
hay que lograr perdón que los
estudiantes en nuestro caso educativo
quieran sepan y puedan quieran quiere
decir que trabajen con entusiasmo y
motivación
tenemos que utilizar esto es fundamental
utilizar nuestra experiencia en nuestros
logros personales y nuestra creatividad
para hacerles llegar un mensaje de
motivación y que trabajen duro para
lograr sus objetivos que sepan
démosle toda la información que tengamos
no nos quedemos con nada y no solo de la
materia sino de todo lo que está
alrededor compartamos la información
noticias novedades
vídeos
facilitemos la de un contacto de un
contacto que tengamos que le pueda
solucionar un problema
estemos informado de alguna beca o
alguna pasantía laboral que le podamos
brindar para que mejoren su situación
y que puedan que tengan los recursos
necesarios para realizar sus tareas
y esto implica que nosotros como
docentes pongamos a disposición del
alumno los las herramientas que tengamos
o las que podamos conseguir para que
ellos puedan trabajar por ejemplo puede
ser de una computadora hasta crear un
aula especial para que ellos estudien
con un pizarrón o una biblioteca de la
especialidad
tenemos que preguntarles e identificar
que necesitan para poder lograr sus
objetivos de la mejor manera
fíjense todo lo que tenemos los docentes
a nuestra disposición para liderar
nuestros cursos
otra característica muy importante que
veíamos antes es la de ser innovadores
yo como alumno me motivó mucho cuando
veo innovación en las prácticas docentes
cuando un docente me enseña a manejar
una nueva herramienta una nueva
aplicación o manejar un nuevo software
son herramientas que voy a utilizar para
esa materia pero que después me llevo
conmigo para utilizarlas a futuro
otra herramienta muy poderosa de la
innovación es sugerirles a los alumnos
que participen en actividades de
investigación
con el tiempo que puedan y que tengan
pero que se inicien en ese ámbito yo
como alumno comencé siendo investigador
en 2011 y me motivó muchísimo a seguir
estudiando y a recibirme
por eso los docentes tenemos que
adquirir nuevas herramientas
métodos complementarios y material
complementario
adquirir nuevas técnicas de trabajo en
grupo
e incentivar la participación en
nuestras clases
en resumen utilizar todos los recursos
que tengamos a disposición para estar al
servicio del alumno
existen un montón de aplicaciones hoy en
día que podemos utilizar para esto para
planificar nuestros cursos podemos hacer
actividades antes durante y después de
la materia
compartirles información crear reuniones
hacer actividades formularios encuesta
una inmensidad de cosas incluso
combinando las se pueden lograr muy muy
buenas actividades
en lo particular e implementado muchas
de ellas en mis cursos logrando muy
buenos resultados tanto en el desempeño
como en la motivación de los alumnos y
esto me fue manifestado a través de
encuestas al finalizar la materia
seguramente muchos de ustedes estén
estudiando actualmente o estudiaron hace
poco hace mucho no importa
pero todos podrán reconocer
que el docente desde su posición debe
influenciar innovar y tratar de cambiar
el mundo porque sus estudiantes cuando
se reciban son los que en el corto
mediano o largo plazo van a hacer que
nosotros en nuestras futuras
generaciones vivamos en un mundo mejor
por lo tanto los invito a que lideren
sus cursos como docentes
seamos los capitanes de este barco donde
el alumno el estudiante vea un destino
con un horizonte claro y despejado y
acompañemos los en ese viaje
de grandes satisfacciones y de las
mejores experiencias para tener el
futuro cuando les pidan que nombren
líderes lo primero que se le venga a la
mente sea los docentes
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]